Kim Kardashian gets a Sweet Serenade
from Usher
[Music]
it's really fun to see the reality star
catches ushers my way Las Vegas
residency with her hair stylist Chris
Appleton and his fiancee Lucas Gage
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah as she was referring to Kim's last
attempt to attend his show six months
ago for her birthday she missed it due
to some bad weather yep but looks like
it was definitely worth the wait check
out Kim belting out Usher's iconic
lyrics
[Music]
Kim's Night Out follows another special
Vegas experience for the beauty Mogul
last weekend is that Northwest
[Applause]
she surprised her daughter North with
tickets to Katy Perry's play residency
and had a total proud moment as her
Mini-Me joined the pop star on stage
[Applause]
[Music]
they got total VIP treatment even
snagging an invite backstage
[Applause]
Bud turns out the true Katy cat in the
room was Kim that's like the best way I
know how to describe it honestly I'm the
biggest Katie
and apparently the feeling's mutual can
I finally be a sister
Katie we don't even know I do you just
gotta roll with it
from an usher Serenade
[Music]
to a Katy Perry dance party
looks like Vegas is treating Kim just
right
foreign